we humans released more than 34 billion
tons of carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere in 2012 that's more than ever
before in spite of all warnings climate
change continues so what will happen if
we don't change
some experts predict that global
temperatures could rise as much as six
degrees Celsius by the end of the
century if those predictions come true
glaciers and polar ice caps will melt
and the sea level will rise entire
archipelagos and some land areas would
be flooded permanently not just the
rural areas would be affected cities
like London Tokyo and New York could end
up underwater the Earth's warming would
cause more water to evaporate resulting
in heavier rainfall and storms River
flooding would become a common
occurrence in some areas rising
temperatures would cause other already
arid regions to become even drier
resulting in more drought and desert
expansion in places like the Sahel
region in Africa
flooding or desertification and a
resulting shortage of food and clean
water would force many people to leave
their homes making them climate change
refugees countless animals and plant
species would be threatened with
extinction because they wouldn't be able
to adapt to the changing conditions
that's why the Intergovernmental Panel
on Climate Change wants to limit the
temperature increased 2 degrees Celsius
so the consequences are still manageable